.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Ständeräte des Kantons Schwyz
sind Föhn und Kuprecht, beide SVP.
Im Nationalrat sind auch alle SVP,
ausser Petra Gössi, FDP,
und Alois Gmür, CVP.
Ich hoffe,
dass ich nicht zu viel gelernt habe.
Mir scheint, je mehr ich gelernt ha-
be, desto weniger kann ich behalten.
Es sind einfach zu viele Namen,
die Zeit ist zu knapp
sowie der tägliche Arbeitsstress,
das ist dann etwas zu viel.
Das Schweizer Einbürgerungsverfahren
ist das strengste in ganz Europa.
Zwar gibt es
nur einen Schweizer Pass,
aber über 2'000 Wege,
ihn zu bekommen.
Das entspricht
der Anzahl Gemeinden in unserem Land.
Zum ersten Mal haben kommunale
Behörden in allen vier Sprachregionen
Zutritt zu ihren sehr vertraulichen
Anhörungen gewährt.
Beim entscheidenden Schritt
vor der Kommission
müssen die Bewerber/-innen
ihre Swissness unter Beweis stellen
und zeigen, dass sie das Räderwerk,
das unser Land antreibt,
bis ins kleinste Detail kennen.
Willkommen
in der Einbürgerungsfabrik,
willkommen
bei "Fabrique des Suisses",
"Far Svizers",
"La Fabbrica degli Svizzeri",
"Schweizer machen".
Gössi, FDP, Gmür, CVP.
Die kann ich mir
einfach nicht merken.
Föhn und Kuprecht, Ständerat.
Nach tagelangem Büffeln ist
der Moment der Einbürgerungsprüfung
für den gebürtigen Ostdeutschen
endlich da.
Andreas
hätte sich nie träumen lassen,
dass er mit 59 Jahren noch einmal
die Angst des Schülers vor dem
weissen Blatt durchstehen muss.
Ungewohnt.
Ich kann mir die nicht merken:
Kuprecht.
So.
Geschätzte Damen und Herren,
ich begrüsse Sie ganz herzlich
zum heutigen Prüfungsabend.
Arbeiten Sie bitte
alleine und selbstständig.
Bücher, Hefte oder auch Handys
legen Sie bitte zur Seite.
Dann verteile ich die Prüfung.
Alles Gute und viel Erfolg.
In Freienbach im Kanton Schwyz
ist die bestandene Prüfung
Voraussetzung für das Einreichen
des Einbürgerungsdossiers.
Andreas hat 75 Min. Zeit,
um zu bestehen.
Fällt er durch,
wird das Verfahren eingestellt.
In Lausanne wird
kein schriftlicher Test verlangt.
Die Einbürgerungscoaches
Brigitte und Douglas
bereiten die Bewerber/-innen
auf die kommunale Anhörung vor.
Ich möchte die heutige Stunde
mit einem Verweis
auf etwas Aktuelles beginnen,
das heute nicht nur hier in Lausanne
stattfindet,
sondern in der ganzen Schweiz.
Daher meine erste Frage:
Seit wann haben die Frauen
im Kanton Waadt das Stimmrecht?
Einmal wurden wir gefragt,
ob wir Schweizermacher seien.
Wir verneinten und sagten, wir seien
Bürgermacher - wenn man so will.
Sie wissen ja, dass es in einer
Demokratie immer drei Gewalten gibt.
Diese drei Gewalten gibt es auf den
Stufen Gemeinde, Kanton und Bund -
nur heissen sie jeweils anders.
Für das Paar aus Sri Lanka ist es
der letzte Kurs vor der Anhörung.
Trotz all der besuchten Stunden
sind die Sivanesans verunsichert
und brauchen ermutigende Worte.
Haben Sie die Unterlagen bekommen,
die ich Ihnen geschickt habe?
Oui.
- Oui.
War es klar?
- Ja, war gut erklärt.
Gut. Sie haben die Anhörung
zu zweit, beide zusammen.
Sie müssen vorbereitet sein.
Man wird Sie fragen,
weshalb Sie Schweizer werden wollen.
Die erste Fangfrage lautet:
Warum wollen Sie Schweizer werden?
Auf diese Frage
gibt es keine Standardantwort.
Das hängt
von jedem einzelnen Werdegang ab.
Die 40 Jahre, die Sie in der Schweiz
leben, haben Sie so weit gebracht.
Wenn Sie gefragt werden, warum,
wollen sie wissen,
was Sie danach machen.
Was werden Sie
mit dem Ausweis machen?
Ein Mann aus unserem Kurs hatte
während der Anhörung ein Blackout.
Er ist mittendrin aufgestanden
und gegangen.
Er war so nervös,
dass er durchgefallen ist.
(Frau) Bonjour.
- (Mann) Bonjour.
Monsieur Saravanamuthu
et Madame Sivanesan?- Oui.
Bonjour Madame.
- Bonjour.
Thanh-My Tran-Nhu.
Seit der Änderung des Bundesgesetzes
muss die Kommission in Lausanne
über 1'600 hängige Gesuche
abarbeiten.
Das Dossier der Sivanesans
ist eines davon.
Nach monatelanger Vorbereitung
entscheiden die nächsten 20 Min.
über ihre Staatszugehörigkeit.
Guten Tag und willkommen, Sie
werden heute von einer Delegation
der Einbürgerungskommission
angehört.
Wir gehören beide
dem Gemeinderat von Lausanne an.
Bevor wir anfangen - können Sie mir
in einigen Worten sagen,
weshalb Sie dieses
Einbürgerungsgesuch gestellt haben?
Weil ich die Schweiz sehr mag.
Meine Kinder sind hier geboren.
Wir sind seit 2005 in der Schweiz.
Die Schweiz
ist ein sehr sicheres Land.
Ja, gut. Und wie ist das bei Ihnen?
Meine Kinder
sind hier zur Welt gekommen
und haben hier studiert.
Wir arbeiten seit 18 Jahren hier.
Auch ich habe ein wenig
zum Schweizer Wohlstand beigetragen.
Gut. Ich sehe, Sie sind
auf Arbeitssuche, Frau Sivanesan.
Wo stehen Sie da im Moment?
- Ich suche eine neue Stelle.
Führen Sie Bewerbungsgespräche?
Entschuldigung,
ich habe Sie nicht verstanden.
Das ist nicht schlimm. Wie viele
Bewerbungsgespräche bis jetzt?
Also Treffen.
Ah, viele.
Hat keines zu etwas geführt?
Nein, ich suche etwas im Verkauf.
Ich habe viele Bewerbungen gemacht.
Obwohl sie
19 Jahre in der Schweiz leben,
bereitet den Sivanesans das Fran-
zösisch immer noch Schwierigkeiten.
Für ihre bisherigen Stellen brauchte
es keine grossen Sprachkenntnisse.
Ihr Dossier
haben sie vor 2018 eingereicht.
Ob sie den Sprachtest
bestehen würden,
den das neue Gesetz verlangt,
ist fraglich.
Die Sprache hat ihren Stellenwert,
aber wir sehen, dass sie klarkommen.
Im Alltag
können sie sich verständlich machen.
Auch bei mir war das so.
Meine Eltern kamen hierher.
Sie sprechen weniger gut Französisch
als ich. Ich bin hier geboren.
Es liegt an meiner Geschichte,
dass mich Menschen berühren,
die sprachlich Mühe haben.
Je nachdem, auf wen sie treffen,
können die Bewerber also hoffen,
dass ihr Sprachniveau
weniger stark ins Gewicht fällt
als die Stichhaltigkeit
ihrer Antworten.
Madame,
können Sie die Flüsse nennen,
die durch den Kanton Waadt fliessen?
La Broye, l'Orbe,
la Venoge, la Veveyse.
Sehr gut.
Welcher See ist der grösste, der
ganz auf Schweizer Boden liegt?
Le Lac des Quatre Cantons?
Ja,
er liegt ganz auf Schweizer Boden.
Er ist aber nicht der grösste.
Gibt es nicht noch einen grösseren,
hier ganz in der Nähe?
Lac Léman, Lac de Neuchâtel ...
Ja, der Neuenburgersee. Sehr gut.
Frau Sivanesan, kennen Sie die Berge
und einige Gipfel?
Ja. Im Kanton Waadt Les Diablerets.
Okay, sehr gut. Wie heissen
die fünf grössten Schweizer Städte?
Zurich, Genève, Bâle,
Lausanne et Berne.
Très bien.
Von der Broye bis Les Diablerets -
bis jetzt schlagen sich
die Sivanesans sehr gut.
Doch die Anhörung
ist noch längst nicht vorbei.
* Hundebellen *
* Schwebende Klänge *
Ich fange jeden Tag sehr früh an.
In der Regel sind es Arbeitstage
mit 11, 12 Std.
Dazu kommen die Tage, an denen ich
mir neue Rezepte ausdenke.
* Er lacht. *
* Er spricht italienisch. *
Für mich ist das Adrenalin pur.
Es gibt so viel zu tun.
Das ist extrem intensiv.
Aber ich weiss, dass ich
heute Abend zufrieden sein werde
und es geniessen kann.
Im Engadinerhof
spielt Paolo eine Schlüsselrolle.
Der Einbürgerungskandidat aus Italien
ist seit über zehn Jahren Küchenchef
des Dreisternehauses.
Ich stehe seit 36 Jahren am Herd.
Ich habe meine Leidenschaft vertieft
und konnte Karriere machen.
Ich brauche diesen Platz, Richard.
Für zwei?
- Für zwei Platten.
* Er spricht italienisch. *
Ich habe alle Stufen durchlaufen:
von der Küchenhilfe zum Koch,
dann zum Souschef
und schliesslich zum Küchenchef.
Zucker, Milch
und stell es zur Seite.
Ja, das ist ein Rezept
nach portugiesischer Art,
ein Rezept von mir.
Dann kommen Milch,
Zucker und Zitrone dazu.
Während der Hochsaison
gleichen Paolos Tage einem Marathon.
Auch bei seiner Frau Ana
ist es ein Kampf gegen die Uhr.
Sie und ihr Team
rasen von Chalet zu Chalet.
Der Samstag ist unser schwarzer Tag.
Alle reisen
zwischen 9 und 11 Uhr ab.
Und um 16 Uhr muss alles stimmen.
* Sie spricht portugiesisch. *
Bei 30 Wohnungen
muss in 7 Std. alles erledigt sein.
Nach der Geburt ihrer Tochter Chiara
hat Ana eine eigene Firma gegründet,
um Arbeit und Familienleben
besser in Einklang zu bringen.
Dank ihrer Ausbildung im Gastgewerbe
liess der Erfolg
nicht lange auf sich warten.
Mit 90 % stammt der grösste Teil
aus Portugal.
Bei Schweizern
ist es vielleicht wegen des Lohns -
es ist schwierig,
Schweizer zu finden, die das machen.
Es ist fertig.
In der Küche
habe ich eine Vase kaputtgemacht.
Nein, es ist eine ganz normale.
Ich kaufe dir eine.
Sie war in der Ecke.
Ja, hallo?
Ich brauche noch 10 Min.
Mit dem Heranwachsen
ihrer Tochter Chiara
im Skiort,
in dem sie langsam heimisch wurden,
wuchs der Wunsch bei Ana und Paolo,
den Schweizer Pass zu beantragen.
Das italienisch-portugiesische Paar
hatte das Verfahren schon einmal
vor vier Jahren eingeleitet.
Mein Mann ging zum Arzt
und ich fragte:
"Wie ist es gegangen? Was ist los?"
Es sei kein Stress,
er müsse nur operiert werden
und ich solle ihm Kaffee machen.
Ich machte ihm einen Kaffee
und er sagte, er habe Krebs.
Es war ein Schock in diesem Moment.
Das Wort Krebs ist kein leichtes,
kein einfaches Wort.
Es ist ein inakzeptables Wort.
Aber dank der Unterstützung
meiner Familie
konnte ich es
mit viel Optimismus annehmen.
Paolo war nicht darauf gefasst.
Den Prostatakrebs hat sein Arzt
bei einer Routinekontrolle
festgestellt.
Er konnte erfolgreich
operiert werden.
Inzwischen macht er
alle sechs Monate einen Bluttest.
Eine Freundin hat mir geraten,
mit der Krankheit zu reden.
Ich habe dem Krebs gesagt,
dass er mir keine Angst macht,
dass er verlieren
und ich gewinnen werde.
Sobald er wieder daheim war,
begannen die schwierigsten Zeiten.
Paolo und Ruhe ...
* Chiara seufzt. *
Das war der schwierigste Monat
nach der Operation.
Im Februar hatte es immer noch
Schnee und er wollte ihn räumen.
Meine Mutter
kam gestresst nach Hause,
mein Vater wollte helfen,
aber er durfte nichts tun.
Wir hatten Mühe, ihn zu beruhigen.
Er sah den Schnee draussen
und konnte nichts machen.
Das war schwierig.
Es war sehr schwierig,
ihn zu Hause zu behalten.
Erst als er das Einverständnis
vom Arzt bekam,
ging es dann langsam wieder.
- Langsam?
Er konnte wieder ins Hotel gehen -
und nur schon Menüs zu schreiben,
beruhigte ihn.
Jetzt hat die Familie
das Einbürgerungsverfahren
wieder aufgenommen.
Wie in der ganzen Schweiz ist das
Gesetz auch in Graubünden eindeutig:
Wer Schweizer werden will, muss für
seinen Unterhalt aufkommen können.
Ohne triftigen Grund bekommt niemand,
der finanzielle Schwierigkeiten hat,
die Schweizer Staatsbürgerschaft.
Das gilt insbesondere
für Sozialhilfebezüger.
Die finanzielle Situation
jeder Kandidatin, jedes Kandidaten
wird daher bis ins letzte Detail
unter die Lupe genommen.
An meiner Arbeit gefällt mir,
dass die ganze Technologie
zur Verfügung steht.
Kommt eine Neuigkeit auf den Markt,
sind wir die Ersten,
die sie einsetzen können.
Ich schätze v.a. meine Kollegen.
Als ich hier angefangen habe,
haben sie mir viel geholfen.
Sie haben mir erklärt,
wie alles geht,
wohin mit den Sachen.
Dawit, der vor 13 Jahren
in die Schweiz geflüchtet ist,
bewirbt sich jetzt
für die Schweizer Staatsbürgerschaft.
Der Eritreer
wollte unbedingt Gipser werden.
Dann musste er seine Lehre aber wegen
einer Klebstoffallergie abbrechen.
Mit der Unterstützung von Suva und IV
liess sich Dawit
zum Verkäufer umschulen.
Grazie.
- Grazie mille.
Dawit hat nie Sozialhilfe bezogen,
aber sein Umschulungsvertrag
läuft demnächst aus.
Um sein Gesuch nicht zu gefährden,
hofft er auf eine Festanstellung.
* Sie sprechen italienisch. *
Sein Chef
kennt das Prozedere bestens.
Er stammt ursprünglich aus Pakistan
und hat sich
vor einigen Jahren einbürgern lassen.
Den schriftlichen Teil
hast du schon bestanden?
Ja, den habe ich gemacht.
- Das ist wichtig.
Aber ich verstehe das nicht ganz:
Man besteht den Test -
warum stellt dann die Gemeinde
noch all die Fragen?
Es wird eher eine Art Gespräch sein,
um sich kennenzulernen.
Sie werden dich bitten,
deine Geschichte zu erzählen,
deinen Weg - solche Dinge halt.
- Ja, das ist in Ordnung.
Und dann werdet ihr
über deinen Alltag reden:
was du jeden Tag machst,
deine Arbeit, die Familie,
die Kontakte zum Umfeld.
Kurz gesagt geht es darum.
Das kriegen wir hin. Yes, we can!
In Freienbach
sind die kniffligen Prüfungsfragen
trotz Vorbereitungskurs
und tagelangem Lernen
eine Herausforderung für Andreas.
Bei der UNO war ich mir am Anfang
nicht so schlüssig ... war es 2000?
Für die Gründung des Kantons Jura
hatte ich erst auch 1971 -
dann fiel mir ein, dass dann
das Frauenwahlrecht war, also 1979.
Es bleibt noch 1 Std.
Deutsch ist meine Muttersprache.
Für mich
war es teilweise auch schwierig,
aber wenn man erst mal noch
Deutsch lernen
und das dann verstehen muss ...
Zudem die sinngemässen
Zusammenhänge, das ist schon ...
Früher habe ich mir darüber
nicht so Gedanken gemacht.
Das ist schon schwierig.
* Unverständliches Flüstern *
(Flüsternd)
Wie hiess der Kanton? Unterwalden?
(Flüsternd) Keine Ahnung.
Schon gut, wir schauen es an.
Nidwalden oder Unterwalden, oder?
- Was?
Nidwalden oder Unterwalden.
- Unterwalden habe ich geschrieben.
Ja, ja.
- Uri, Schwyz, Unterwalden.
Für die Mengstabs steht die Anhörung
vor der Einbürgerungskommission
kurz bevor.
Dawit hat alle Hürden genommen
und das Dossier zusammengestellt.
Wie Andreas
hat auch er die Schulbank gedrückt
und Stunden
im Tessiner Swissness-Kurs gebüffelt.
Die Unterlagen zum anspruchsvollen
Test hat er alle behalten.
Zuerst habe ich
die Geografie gelernt.
Ich wusste, wo jeder Kanton liegt,
kannte alle Strassenschilder,
woher sie kommen -
alle Wappen,
alle Kantonshauptorte,
Bundesrat, Tessiner Staatsrat.
Meine grösste Angst war,
die Namen der Ratsmitglieder
nicht mehr zu wissen.
Ich sah mir Fotos an und dachte:
Den kenne ich und weiss den Namen,
bin aber nicht sicher,
ob er es auch wirklich ist.
Bei der Prüfung
habe ich von 42 Fragen
nur zwei falsch beantwortet.
Wenn du einem Schweizer
all die Fragen stellst -
einem richtigen Schweizer -,
bin ich nicht sicher,
ob er das alles weiss.
Um diese Einbürgerungskurse zu
besuchen, kommen die Kandidierenden
an Orten zusammen,
die meist etwas ausserhalb liegen
und nicht wirklich einladend sind -
wie dieser hier,
mitten im Industriegebiet.
Heute Abend legen wir den Fokus
auf die Gemeindeebene.
Die Einbürgerungswilligen
besuchen einen obligatorischen Kurs,
der kostenpflichtig ist
und 40 Std. dauert.
Zehn Module à 4 Std. abends
und am Samstag tagsüber.
Früher haben die Berufsschulen
und auch viele Gemeinden
Kurse zur Vorbereitung
auf die Anhörungen
vor den kommunalen
Einbürgerungsbehörden angeboten.
In der Vergangenheit hat es
vereinzelt Fehlentscheide gegeben,
wegen der politischen Haltung
derjenigen,
die die Anhörung durchgeführt haben.
Es gab Leute, die je nach Herkunft
der Bewerber vorschlugen,
Gesuche zu genehmigen
bzw. abzulehnen.
Die zuständige Behörde
hat dann entschieden,
einen Kurs
und eine Prüfung einzuführen.
Im Bemühen,
möglichst objektiv zu sein.
(Mann) Guten Tag,
Sie sind wegen der Prüfung da?
Haben Sie Ihre Dokumente?
(Courbon) Hier im Tessin
befinden wir uns
in einem kulturellen
und sozialen Kontext,
in dem Themen
rund um Einbürgerung und Migration
heikel sind.
Auf gar keinen Fall
soll der Eindruck entstehen,
dass der Schweizer Pass allen,
die ihn wollen,
einfach geschenkt wird.
Der Test dauert 1 Std.
Die Fragen sind anspruchsvoll.
Wer durchfällt,
muss sechs Monate warten,
bevor er wieder antreten kann.
Für die Kandidaten
ist das eine intensive Prüfung.
Zu viele Zahlen, zu viele Daten -
ich kann mir das nicht merken.
Im Teil Gesellschaft und Wirtschaft
waren ganz komische Fragen.
Wie viele Kilometer Autobahn
gibt es im Tessin?
Wie viele Quadratmeter
Naturschutzgebiet?
Wo ist die höchste Bevölkerungs-
dichte? Da musste ich überlegen.
Das Konzept des Referendums,
die Unterschriften und ...
Jetzt kann ich mich nicht mehr
an die Frage erinnern.
Wie viele Personen haben 2016
Sozialhilfe bezogen?
Wie viele Nummernschilder pro Kopf
sind eingelöst?
Wir sind in die Schweiz gekommen,
um zu arbeiten.
Wir hatten keine Zeit,
um irgendetwas anderes zu machen.
Ich habe immer
wie ein Verrückter gearbeitet.
Im Tessin ist die Hürde
aus obligatorischem Test
und Sprachkenntnissen
für viele zu hoch.
Über die Hälfte der Eingebürgerten
stammt aus Italien.
Ah! Rezyklierte Menge: 47 %.
- Jetzt hast du mich erwischt.
(Courbon) Die Voraussetzungen,
um die Schweizer Staatsbürgerschaft
zu beantragen,
sind wirklich sehr hoch.
Sie sind viel strenger
als in all unseren Nachbarländern.
Ich halte das Einbürgerungsverfahren
nicht für einen Hürdenlauf.
Es stimmt: Wenn man
die Landessprache nicht beherrscht,
z.B. Italienisch hier im Tessin,
kann das schon hinderlich sein.
Aber wenn die Sprache
das Problem ist,
dann darf man sich schon fragen,
ob der Kandidat
wirklich integriert ist.
Endlich ein Sonntag zum Entspannen
für Enea Petrini.
Freizeit ist für den
hyperaktiven Lega-Politiker rar.
Beim Fischen
bin ich weniger patriotisch.
Ich fische nicht im Ticino,
weil ich Tessiner bin
und im Kanton Tessin lebe.
Jeder Fischer
hat so seinen Lieblingsfluss
und ich mag diese Gegend hier
einfach sehr,
den Oberlauf des Ticino.
Unser Kanton ist bekannt
für seinen Lokalpatriotismus.
Wir werden den Eindruck nicht los,
dass wir auf Bundesebene
immer die Letzten sind,
die an die Reihe kommen.
Isoliert am unteren Ende des Landes,
oft mit Italien gleichgesetzt
wegen der Sprache und der Mentalität,
ständig unter Druck wegen der Grenze.
Das Tessin gilt oft als Sonderfall.
Die Überzeugung, eine
unverstandene Minderheit zu sein,
nährt Petrini seit über 25 Jahren
mit der Lega,
einer Partei,
die sich bei Einbürgerungen
für den Handlungsspielraum
der Gemeinden stark macht.
Wir werden oft
als Schweizermacher betitelt.
Aber man muss auch bedenken,
dass in Lugano allein letzte Woche
im Gemeinderat
72 Gesuche bewilligt wurden.
Also Schweizermacher ja -
aber wegen der Menge.
Nicht, weil wir den Leuten
den Schweizer Pass schenken.
Im Tessin ist die entscheidende
die kommunale Ebene.
Das System ist anfechtbar,
denn man kann das Resultat
positiv beeinflussen -
je nachdem, in welcher Gemeinde man
sein Gesuch einreicht.
In der Schweiz kann jede Gemeinde
das Verfahren
nach eigenem Gutdünken anpassen.
Fazit: Es gibt 2'200 Wege,
Schweizer zu werden -
ein regelrechtes Dickicht.
Die Gefahr der Ungleichbehandlung
ist fester Bestandteil
des Einbürgerungsparcours.
Schweizweit betrachtet blitzt jede
fünfte Person bei der Anhörung ab.
In Lausanne entsprechen die Zahlen
dem Landesmittel.
Wie ist die Schweiz politisch
aufgebaut? Die drei Gewalten?
Legislative,
Exekutive und Judikative.
Grob gesehen sind das neun Felder,
etwa so.
Hier sehen Sie die Legislative,
die Exekutive und die Judikative
auf Stufe Bund, Kanton und Gemeinde.
Können Sie uns sagen,
was wir auf der Stufe Legislative
beim Bund finden?
Wie heisst das Gremium
und wie viele Mitglieder hat es?
Die Legislative auf Bundesebene,
das eidg. Parlament heisst ...
* Er räuspert sich. *
... Ständerat und Nationalrat.
Im Nationalrat
sind es 200 Mitglieder,
im Ständerat zwei pro Kanton.
Die Halbkantone
haben aber nur je eine Person.
Insgesamt sind es 46, total 246
in der Legislative, dem Parlament.
Okay.
Und die beiden Kammern zusammen?
Ja,
die Vereinigte Bundesversammlung.
Wir passen unsere Fragen immer an.
Wenn wir sehen,
dass ein Kandidat Mühe hat,
korrigieren wir etwas nach unten.
Und wenn wir merken,
dass er sich wohlfühlt,
drücken wir etwas -
das gibt etwas Bonus.
Und nun zu Ihnen.
Die kantonale Legislative.
Der Staatsrat
mit sieben Mitgliedern.
Die Präsidentin
ist Frau Nuria Gorrite.
Gut. Weiteres zu den Institutionen?
- Non.
Gut, von uns aus
ist die Anhörung abgeschlossen.
Ich gebe Frau Heberlein das Wort.
Nun wird sich
die Einbürgerungskommission beraten
und dem Gemeinderat
eine Empfehlung abgeben.
Sie erhalten den Entscheid der Stadt
in vier bis sechs Wochen per Post.
Bei einem positiven Entscheid müssen
Sie für den Verwaltungsaufwand
mit mind. eineinhalb Jahren rechnen,
bis Sie den Schweizer Pass erhalten.
Merci beaucoup.
- Merci beaucoup.
Für die Sivanesans ist es bereits
Zeit, sich zu verabschieden.
Bei einem positiven Entscheid
müssen sie sich in Geduld üben.
In Lausanne braucht es zwei bis drei
Jahre, um Schweizer zu werden.
Bei den drei Themen
lief es fehlerfrei, ausgezeichnet.
Bei der Sprache können wir
gut setzen. Was meinst du?
Genügend bis gut.
- Genügend.
Ja, ja, sie verstehen alle Fragen.
Ja und man versteht sie.
- Danach geht es nicht weiter.
Ja. Setzen wir genügend.
Die Kommissionsmitglieder verfügen
über einen Ermessensspielraum.
Nicht immer lassen sie
bei den Anhörungen Nachsicht walten.
Ich nehme ein typisches Beispiel:
Ein Student, der hier geboren ist,
verpatzt die Prüfung.
Da habe ich dann Lust, zu sagen:
Nein, den lasse ich durchfallen,
weil er keine Entschuldigung hat.
Dass es heute so gut lief,
verdankt das Paar aus Sri Lanka
auch Brigitte und Douglas
und ihrem Vorbereitungskurs.
Die beiden,
die selbst auch eingebürgert wurden,
engagieren sich seit jeher
im Bereich Integration.
Die Finanzierung der AHV.
Mein Vater ist Venezolaner,
meine Mutter stammt aus Lausanne.
Ich kam 1997 in die Schweiz,
habe aber als Jugendliche
ein paar Jahre hier gelebt.
Und was passiert, wenn einer
in den Bundesrat gewählt wird?
Ich bin in Caracas geboren.
Meine Nationalität?
Venezolanisch und schweizerisch.
Und wenn die Leute fragen,
sage ich: "Ich stamme aus Ollon."
So steht's auf meiner ID.
Schweizer werden heisst nicht,
die eigenen Wurzeln zu verleugnen.
Douglas und Brigitte haben sich
in Venezuela kennengelernt.
Dort ist Brigitte 1985
auch Schweizerin geworden.
Bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt
hatten nur Männer das Recht,
ihre Staatszugehörigkeit
an die Nachkommen weiterzugeben.
Ich habe davon profitiert,
dass die Schweizerinnen
im Laufe der Zeit
die Möglichkeit hatten,
ihre Nationalität
für ihre Kinder zu verlangen.
Meine Mutter hat mich gefragt,
ob ich das will.
Natürlich habe ich Ja gesagt.
So bekam ich den Schweizer Pass
in Venezuela.
Dank des roten Passes konnten sie
das krisengebeutelte Venezuela
Ende der 90er-Jahre
mit ihren drei Kindern verlassen.
In Lausanne
mussten sie bei null angefangen.
Ihre Ingenieursabschlüsse wurden
in der Schweiz nicht anerkannt.
Douglas und die Kinder
mussten erst mal Französisch lernen.
Für die fünfköpfige Familie
mit ihren bescheidenen Einkünften
war der Weg steinig.
Das hat sie motiviert,
sich für Ausländer/-innen
einzusetzen.
* Spanischer Gesang *
Wir mussten praktisch alles
aus dem Stegreif lernen.
Als wir dann mit der
Vereinstätigkeit begonnen haben,
wollten wir die Leute schonen -
zumindest die, die nach uns kamen -,
ihnen bei dem ganzen Prozess helfen.
Die beiden haben ihre Aufnahme in der
Schweiz sehr unterschiedlich erlebt.
(Brigitte)
Ich hatte immer den Eindruck,
die Schweizer
seien ein wohlwollendes Volk.
Das klingt vielleicht nach Klischee,
aber so empfinde ich das.
(Douglas)
Ich habe einen anderen Zugang.
Der Schweizer ist einer,
der dich beobachtet.
Er macht nie den ersten Schritt,
er beobachtet.
Die Schale ist ziemlich hart,
aber du kannst sie knacken.
Wenn du sie geknackt hast, kannst du
rein und wirst gut aufgenommen.
* Energiegeladener Gesang,
Schlussklang *
* Jubel, Pfiffe *
* Tiefe Streichmusik,
sanfter Gesang *
In Freienbach scheint diese Schale
besonders hart zu sein.
Selbst Kommissionsmitglied
Annina Herrmann musste sich anpassen,
als sie aus ihrer Heimat Graubünden
nach Schwyz kam.
Genau vor 30 Jahren
machte ich die Schiffsprüfung.
Hallo zusammen!
Geht ihr auch hinüber?
Für mich als Bergkind
war das furchtbar.
Der pensionierten
leitenden Pflegefachfrau
glückte die Integration
dank der Familiengründung.
Meine Familie
ist mir wichtig im Leben.
Wir haben zwei Kinder mit Partnern.
Es spielt keine Rolle,
was sie machen.
Sie sollen mit dem, was sie machen,
glücklich sein
und sich wertvoll fühlen.
Grüezi.
(Mann)
Wir sind 30 Jahre verheiratet.
Frische Fische!
(Mann)
Konkret nahm ich ihr den Parkplatz.
Ich sagte nonchalant, das sei egal,
ich müsse nur schnell da hin.
Sie sagte, nein, das gehe so nicht.
Das ist mir irgendwie eingefahren.
Diese Bestimmtheit und Direktheit
faszinierten mich.
Ich würde sagen,
sie ist wie eine Löwin:
sehr beschützend,
sie schaut auf alle,
sie ist sehr fürsorglich,
macht aber auch klare Ansagen.
Annina Herrmann ist zutiefst
mit der Schweiz verbunden.
Auch als Mitglied
der Einbürgerungskommission
findet sie, dass man sich diese
Postkartenidylle verdienen muss.
Die Schweiz, Schweizer Bürger
zu werden, ist natürlich beliebt.
Die Leute erzählen uns ja immer,
warum sie das wollen,
und die meisten sagen:
"Es ist ein sicheres Land,
man kann sich darauf verlassen."
"Die Polizei und unsere Justiz
sind gerecht."
Sie schätzen uns Schweizer
eigentlich auch
als freundliche Menschen ein.
Das sind so die Hauptargumente.
Andreas wohnt zwar noch
in der Familienwohnung,
hat aber neue Mitbewohner.
Seine jüngste Tochter Lisa
hat der Schweiz den Rücken gekehrt,
nachdem ihr Einbürgerungsgesuch
abgelehnt wurde.
Mittlerweile lebt der ganze Rest
der Familie wieder in Deutschland.
Gute Nachrichten
werden aus der Ferne übermittelt.
Da albert sie rum.
Ich bin Opa geworden.
Ja, da ist man stolz.
So weit ist meine grosse Tochter
nicht entfernt.
Am 17. werde ich sie besuchen.
Sie wohnt in Stuttgart.
Das sind Flora, Illara, Saskia.
Sie ist von hier aus näher
als von meinem vorherigen Wohnort.
Meine kleine Tochter fliegt viel.
Sie arbeitet als Kabinenmanager
und ist dadurch
auch ziemlich unabhängig.
Trotz Einsamkeit und Distanz
hält Andreas am Entschluss fest,
Schweizer zu werden.
Einige Hundert Meter entfernt
beugt sich Prüfer Roland Jost
mit kritischem Blick
über die Tests von Andreas
und den anderen Kandidaten.
Das ist auch wieder eine Frage:
"Alters-
und Hinterbliebenenversicherung".
Grundsätzlich heisst es Alters-
und Hinterlassenenversicherung.
Da gebe ich einfach
einen halben Punkt.
Das ist aber sonst
korrekt geschrieben.
Das ist sehr gut abgefasst.
Um zu bestehen,
muss Andreas zwei Drittel der Fragen
richtig beantworten.
"Was wird in der 2. Säule
versichert?"
Die Antwort ist:
"Alter, Invalidität, Todesfall
(zur Ergänzung der 1. Säule)."
Er schreibt: "Sicherung des Lebens-
standards, zusätzlich zur AHV."
Ja ...
Eigentlich richtig -
ich lasse das mal so stehen.
Wie das Tessin hat auch Schwyz
einen kantonalen Einbürgerungstest
eingeführt,
und das Risiko von Willkür
auf Gemeindeebene zu unterbinden.
Wir deklarieren
gegenüber den Gemeinden,
dass die Fragen,
die die Schweiz betreffen -
also das Wissen in Geografie,
Geschichte, usw. -, abgedeckt sind.
Im Einbürgerungsgespräch
werden dann v.a.
die örtlichen Gegebenheiten geprüft,
die Integration im Dorf
und in der Gemeinde.
* Schwebende Klänge *
In Pontresina
wird erfolgreiche Integration
v.a. an der Erwerbsfähigkeit
der Bewerber/-innen gemessen.
Für Paolo ist die Arbeit heilig.
Den Nationalfeiertag nutzt er,
um seiner Fantasie
freien Lauf zu lassen.
Schon als Kind
konnte ich gut malen und zeichnen.
Mein Traum war es,
eine Kunstschule zu besuchen.
Aber damals war die Schule
zu weit weg von zu Hause
und uns fehlte das Geld.
Deshalb habe ich mich
nach einer Schule umgeschaut,
die mich
genauso stark motivieren könnte.
Da bin ich
auf die Kochschule gekommen.
Ich habe mir gesagt: Da geht es ja
auch um Kunst und Farben.
Heute Abend spielen Paolo und
seine Küchenbrigade die Hauptrolle.
Ein kleiner Applaus für die Küche?
Danke schön!
So schweizerisch
der Nationalfeiertag auch sein mag,
ohne ausländische Arbeitskraft
ginge rein gar nichts.
Und es ist Engadiner Fleisch,
100 %, Filet. Eine Scheibe?
Portoghesi Kartoffeln?
Der 1. August steht für mich
für Emotionen, Fahnen und für Leute,
die in Feststimmung sind und
den besonderen Tag feiern wollen.
Eine?
Am 1. August essen wir bei Paolo.
Das ist meine Frau.
Eigentlich ist das ein Feiertag,
aber wir sind es gewohnt,
dass es
ein normaler Arbeitstag ist.
Jedenfalls für Leute,
die im Tourismus arbeiten.
Ciao, Papi.
- Dimmi. Agnello?- No.
Filetti di manzo?
- Sì.
(Ana) Klar wäre es schön, zu dritt
mit dem Hund spazieren zu gehen
oder ein Picknick zu machen,
aber es gehört einfach dazu.
* Anschwellende sphärische Klänge *
Dieser 1. August
ist ein besonderer Tag
für die italienisch-portugiesische
Familie.
Gerade haben sie erfahren, dass ihr
Dossier vom Kanton bewilligt wurde.
Der nächste Schritt
ist die Anhörung vor der Gemeinde
durch Thomas Walther.
Der Hotelier ist auch Präsident
der Bürgergemeinde Pontresina.
Bürgergemeinden sind
eine typisch schweizerische Eigenart,
eine Art Parallelgewalt
zur politischen Gemeinde.
Geht's dir gut?
Wenn wir so gefahren werden,
ist alles gut.
Ich bin der älteste Bürger.
- Ja, ich weiss.
In fünf Jahren
feiern wir den 100. hier.
Du bist dann eingeladen.
Die Bürgergemeinde ist eigentlich
das Langzeitgedächtnis
einer Gemeinde.
Es ist eine Art
Vereinigung von Leuten,
denen Pontresina am Herzen liegt.
Die Bürgergemeinden
besitzen nach wie vor
viele Grundstücke und auch Wald.
Der Bürgergemeinde Pontresina
gehört sogar ein Stück vom Gletscher.
Und die Bürgergemeinde
hat das alleinige Recht
zu entscheiden, wer Schweizer wird.
* Er spricht rätoromanisch. *
Die Bürgerversammlung
stimmt nicht etwa ab,
sie nimmt die Einbürgerungsentscheide
von Präsident und Rat zur Kenntnis.
Kommen wir zu Traktandum 3:
Einbürgerungen.
Eingebürgert wurde Marco Meisen,
dann ein Bruder von Frau Piedermann,
den wir letztes Jahr
wiedereingebürgert haben,
das ist Eduard Piedermann -
mit "P" geschrieben.
Ferner werden Frau Sylvia Gallinger
und ihr Sohn Sven eingebürgert.
Sie kennen sie sicher, sie ist die
Frau des langjährigen Bademeisters.
So viel zum Thema Einbürgerungen.
Die positiven Entscheide pro Jahr
kann man hier an einer Hand abzählen.
Wer sich in der kleinen Berggemeinde
einbürgern lassen will,
entkommt der sozialen Kontrolle
nicht.
Den Mitgliedern der zuständigen
Kommission entgeht nichts.
Wir hatten vor ein paar Jahren ein
Beispiel, wo wir zwar die Kinder,
aber nicht die Eltern
eingebürgert haben.
Wir beurteilen keine Werte,
sondern wir äussern unsere Werte
und sagen,
dass sie nicht verhandelbar sind.
Ich rede im Jahr 2020 nicht mehr
über Gleichberechtigung
der Geschlechter
oder Glaubens- und Meinungsfreiheit,
die für uns zum Glück
selbstverständlich sind.
Man kann machen, was man will,
aber wenn man diese Basis nicht hat
oder nicht danach leben will,
kann man das wohl machen -
aber nicht mit dem Schweizer Pass.
Das werden wir
wenn möglich verhindern.
Glaubt er, dass die rote Linie
überschritten ist,
zögert Thomas Walther nicht,
seine Macht geltend zu machen -
auch auf die Gefahr hin, dass
Familien dadurch entzweit werden.
* Lautsprecherdurchsage *
Wenn ich weiss,
dass ich am nächsten Tag
ein Turnier habe und spiele,
kann ich nicht schlafen.
Ich bin zu nervös.
Wenn ich dann auf dem Feld stehe,
zählt nur noch das Spiel.
... due, uno.
* Pfiff *
Ermiyas kickt seit drei Jahren
beim FC Rapid Lugano.
Sein Vater Dawit
lässt keines seiner Spiele aus.
Ermiyas, dietro di lui, dai!
Bravo!
(Ermiyas) Es freut mich,
dass mein Vater zuschauen kommt.
Er ist mit meiner Leistung
immer zufrieden
und ich begrüsse ihn jedes Mal
während des Spiels.
(Dawit) No! No! No! No!
* Pfiff, Jubel, Applaus *
Integration bedeutet ja nicht nur
Arbeit, Sprache, Kultur.
Integrieren kann man sich auch
über den Sport.
Und er spielt ja gut.
Ich wünsche mir, dass es
auch in der Schule gut läuft.
Die Kinder
denken ja oft nur ans Spielen.
Ich möchte,
dass sie in beidem erfolgreich sind.
Ich bin sehr stolz auf ihn.
Ihr wart super, denn ihr wisst,
dass wir immer kämpfen müssen.
Wir spielen immer gegen die Grossen.
Also Jungs, immer mit der Ruhe.
Wir spielen einfach weiter -
so gut, wie wir können.
Die Jungs
haben es gut untereinander,
sie fühlen sich gleichwertig.
Es gibt stärkere und weniger starke,
blonde und schwarze,
Linksfüsser und Rechtsfüsser,
Leute aus dem einen Land
und Leute aus einem anderen.
Ich bin der Einzige,
der mit links spielt! Ciao!
Ich fühle mich mehr als Schweizer,
weil ich hier geboren bin
und Eritrea
eigentlich gar nicht kenne.
Es wäre super,
den Schweizer Pass zu bekommen.
Ich könnte nach Eritrea reisen
und auch sonst
ganz viele Länder kennenlernen.
Und ich könnte
in die Schweizer Nationalmannschaft.
A giocare
e diventare un bravo calciatore.
(Mann) Dai, prendila!
* Rufe, Applaus *
Oh ja.
Das ist der Brief vom Berufs-
bildungszentrum wegen der Prüfung.
Ich öffne ihn gleich.
"Prüfungsresultat".
"Es freut uns,
Ihnen mitteilen zu können,
dass Sie
die nötige Anzahl Punkte erreicht
und somit die Prüfung
mit Erfolg bestanden haben."
Oh ja.
Mal schauen, ob auch steht ...
49 von 55 Punkten.
Besser, als ich dachte.
Das ist schon mal sehr entspannend,
so kann man sich nun
auf die anderen Sachen vorbereiten.
* Hektische elektronische Klänge *
Endlich erhält Dawit
das Schreiben der Stadt Lugano.
"Einbürgerungsanhörungen".
Mit mir?
- Aber ja.
Zur Anhörung eingeladen ist auch
seine 14-jährige Tochter Hermela.
"Einbürgerungsgesuch".
Du wirst sehen, das wird klappen.
Ich weiss nicht so recht,
ich habe Angst.
In Lausanne machen sich die
Benedettos für ihre Anhörung parat.
Wir werden ja sehen.
Diesem Termin
sehen die beiden mit Sorgen entgegen.
Thomas Walther hat
Familie Corona-Cardoso aufgeboten.
Die Anhörung steht unmittelbar bevor.
Vor diesem wichtigen Termin
haben Paolo, Ana und Chiara
die ruhige Zwischensaison genutzt
und sind noch einmal
nach Portugal gereist.
Andreas ist
Richtung Deutschland aufgebrochen.
Er ist zum zweiten Mal
Grossvater geworden.
Und seine jüngste Tochter Lisa
wird vom Albtraum erzählen,
den sie 2015 bei ihrer Anhörung
in Freienbach erlebt hat.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Madeleine Gassner - 2020